deux ans et demi après avoir formulé
leur demande les premiers ministres
arrivent d'un pas déterminer alors
rencontre avec Justin Trudeau
mais pas question de se laisser marcher
sur les pieds précise François Legault
parce que ce financement additionnel
soit donné sans conditions pour parler
des résultats qu'on veut livrer pour les
systèmes de santé l'offre que Justin
Trudeau met sur la table comprend 2
milliards versets immédiatement pour les
besoins urgents comme les salles
d'urgence les listes d'attentes et pour
les hôpitaux pédiatriques ensuite les
transfert augmenteront d'au moins 5% par
année pour les 5 prochaines années ce
qui équivaut un montant de 17,3
milliards de dollars puis Ottawa propose
25 milliards en disant pour des entente
bilatérales avec chacune des provinces
c'est donc 46,2 milliards de nouveaux
investissements pour un total de 196
milliards de dollars qui seront
transférés aux provinces jusqu'en 2034
les premiers ministres des provinces ont
les pression d'avoir été entendues en
partie la bonne nouvelle c'est qu'il y a
pas de conditions mais sur le plan
financier c'est très loin de ce qu'on a
besoin ce
nous demandions 28 milliards dès la
première année pour atteindre le fameux
35%, mais selon la proposition on
recevra moins de 5 milliards dit la
première ministre du Manitoba
le problème du déséquilibre fiscal
ajoute son collègue québécois le
rattrapage qu'on demandait n'est pas au
rendez-vous donc ça ne règle pas le
problème fondamental du financement des
soins de santé les premiers ministres
des provinces et des territoires
accueillent avec prudence l'offre de
Justin Trudeau aucun n'a les moyens de
se priver d'argent neuf à investir dans
son système de santé ils vont donc
prendre quelques jours de réflexion
avant de répondre plus formellement à la
proposition ici Valérie Gamache reste au
Canada
Ottawa